joining us for more reaction we have
John Solomon a reporter for the hill
newspaper former Secret Service agent
Dan bond Gino and talk radio host and
attorney Leo Terrell thank you all for
joining us here tonight Leo I want to
start with you what they we all thought
that I mean I thought and I think a lot
of people thought that the president may
have some read actions but would
ultimately release this memo but it's
not coming out tonight how are you and
the Democrats going to react to that
well it's a sham and I'll tell you why
just last week Jason
despite a public announcement by the FBI
not to release the Republican memo
President Trump released a memo shame on
the president because it is very clear
he did not want this memo released
because it negates his argument last
week that he's exonerated it is
embarrassing and shameful there is
nothing that memo that would have
prevented it released today except that
was bad PR for President Trump but Leo
did you see anything in the in the Nunez
memo that was dealt with with classified
material about sources and methods there
was a little I'm gonna draw I'm gonna
put I'm gonna pull rank on everybody I'm
the lawyer there's in this group and I'm
gonna simply tell you this the FBI said
don't release it and they released it
notwithstanding jqn ears but there was
no there was no classified material
about sources and methods in the Nunez
memo correct it was it was classified
those information about the procedure
and the manner in which a warrant is
obtained that information should not
have been released to the American
public but it was beneficial to Donald
Trump and he released it notwithstanding
a public statement from the FBI and
Department of Justice not to release it
okay John let's go to this there's also
a word about a second dossier that is
out there tell us what you know about
that so in the summer of 2016 there's
another pipeline of Clinton related
information coming into the State
Department and then - Mike - Christopher
Steele then to the FBI it comes through
two guys that we've heard from the past
and the old Clinton years in the 90s you
might have been involved in some of
those investigations
Cody share private I hung around the
Clintons a lot and Sidney Blumenthal one
of their closest friends kind of their I
spy inside the Clinton
pain and they put the information in and
tracks very closely to what steel has so
you have all this information coming in
I predict when we're done all four
sources of the information that the FBI
is to use to launch the investigation
against Donald Trump every one of them
is going to have a connection to the
Clinton campaign now Dan one of the
concerns that's out there Politico is
reporting tonight that Steve Bannon may
have actually been picked up on some of
these surveillances how does that is
that strike it mean it's right in the
heart of the campaign and they've also
got now Steve Bannon according to
Politico that they were spying on as
well well Jason we know two things right
now despite that an interesting little
opening by Leo there
we know that the Obama team spied on the
Trump team okay that's not in dispute
how it happened may be in dispute but we
know that happened what we also know is
we know because there are court
transcripts okay there's an actual
record of this that no Democrats going
to be able to run from and no Democrats
gonna have plausible deniability on we
know that the bulk of the material that
won in front of those FISA Court judges
was provided by in fact the dossier a
dossier that came from two sources
Russians who passed it through
Christopher Steele and Clinton campaign
associates all the Democrat memos in the
world are going to change those two
simple facts full stop you know that's
tip less that's classic talking points
dan you know FBI gets their information
from all different sources the bottom
line is let me have no wait oh come on
now let me get a page out of Jason's
book trey Gowdy you know him dan don't
you trey Gowdy says there is a need to
proceed with the Russian probe you don't
disagree with trey Gowdy do you Dan Oh
about that but we're talking about yeah
it's all good and then surveilling
surveilling people that now has expanded
to include potentially at least what
we're looking at a report that's put out
by Politico tonight that includes Steve
banning and that does beg the question
of who else's use let me go to John for
a second John where do you see this
going in the next week or two I think
the last piece of the evidence that came
in that substantiated the FISA warrant
at the beginning came from this
ambassador right this Australian
ambassador
here's Papadopoulos in the bar drunk and
having conversation with him I think
we're gonna learn a lot more about that
ambassador and where his loyalties might
be when that's all put together yeah I
think you're gonna find out four fours
four out of four things the FBI use to
start listening in a trump campaign
comes back to the Clinton family now Leo
it does any of this does any of this
concern you and and I got to ask you
give us an aunt let me look right in the
camera and tell us if Donald Trump had
done this against a Democrat you can't
tell me that you just be sitting idly by
saying oh the FBI is just acted
perfectly in this instance Jason I'm
looking you and the American public
straight in the eye right now I'm
leaning forward Donald Trump is
basically attacking every institution in
the American government he controlled
the CIA the FBI Department of Justice
you want me to drink that kool-aid and
believe that the FBI the entire
governmental security agencies or
against Donald Trump
you want me to drink that kool-aid today
on national TV you believe that Dan you
believe that the entire - you babble
yeah Leo you know you you it's amazing
you do this liberals through this all
the time they never actually addressed
what you say he goes on to something
else here's what notice he never
addressed that all the substance of what
I said we know for a fact the Obama team
spied on the Trump team we know the
information was provided by Steele
through the Russians and we also know
the information was provided through
Clinton consigliere
I know because one of them wrote an
op-ed in the Washington Post today
basically admitting to it and another
one went on a weekend news show Victoria
Nuland and admitted to with you now Leo
will go on about the Russians again
because that's what they do
no no no I'll play your game and
therefore what what are you making
conclusion tell us your conclusion and
therefore what what who's who could here
for the Obama team i I mean you may be
hard of hearing but I already said it
the Obama team spied on the Trump team
there's still no probable cause that
anyone on the Trump team was a foreign
agent violation of US law no one's
produced a scintilla of evidence of
Russian collusion and you're still
sticking by that this was all done great
because you're a police state supporter
and distorted let me go to Jesse let me
go let me look let me let me go to the
John here there are still a mountain of
text messages that we have not seen drew
and it is there any fallout that you're
seeing I mean the FBI put out there that
they couldn't find these missing text
messages and they showed up only to have
the inspector general I think it was a
lot less than 48 hours ago and find
that's right
yeah I think the inspector general's
report in March will be one of the most
seminal moments in this whole thing
it'll help them resolve how much
politics was involved and how much
legitimate law enforcement when we see
the full breadth of what the independent
IG does I think we're gonna have a more
complete picture and this debate may
take an entirely different tact they
will leo are you willing to accept with
the in black jack if he's making this
prediction about the inspector general
report can you please have me all when
when this report comes out because I
hope according to Dan there could be all
these indictments against the Obama
administration is doom it's a great way
to deflect from the Donald Trump and the
Russian probe great move dance very
smart seconds 15 seconds Leo what's your
single best piece of evidence that
Donald Trump colluded with Russians the
single best one what is it best piece of
evidence I'll use the trey gowdy
approach up a couple of Russia's were
meeting with Dom Greg Audi no I know
I'll use the same one that he used the
Trump's meeting with the Russians at
Trump Tower pretty solid evidence you
get the last word where do you where do
you see the genius case there yeah maybe
Mark Warner should be under arrest to
them for trying to set up at a meeting
with the Russian a Democrat Senator from
Virginia
unbelievable then he had nothing always
before the one thing I think we can all
agree about we'll be talking about this
next week we've got to move on thank you
all have a wonderful weekend I
appreciate you being here